mein name ist klug heute herzlich
willkommen hier heute meine damen und
herren endlich mal wieder zu einem
weiteren teil dieser serie liegt seit
wochen nicht auf meinen kanal gebracht
habe und zwar e-mails mittel luca ich
habe heute mal wieder einige der
bescheuert den ebay feld führte wer sich
ebay kleinanzeigen fels vorbereitet und
ich würde sagen wir fangen direkt an mit
diesem angebot 658 ikea stifter für 10
euro jemand hat einfach 658 her stifter
geklaut
und verkauft jetzt für zehn euro auf
ebay das ist geld machen auf einem
komplett neuen level ja als nächstes
verkauft jemand auf ebay sein sofa mit
200 euro es würde gepostet vor 15
stunden also ein ganz normales angebot
denkt man das hier ist allerdings das
einzige bild von dem sofa ja da kriegt
man bestimmt keinen kalten hintern immer
darauf sitzt machen allerdings direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten ebay
kleinanzeigen angebot und zwar verkauft
hier jemand seinen ford fiesta 1.4 klein
und sparsam vieles neuwertig steht dann
noch hinter für 9990 euro und es ist
auch wieder auf ersten blicken dann
zumal das angebot bis man dann die
fahrzeug bilder zieht
und ja also hier wurde überhaupt nichts
bevor die shops kommen allerdings direkt
zum nächsten ebay verkauft jemand
einfach altes brot zu schade zum
wegwerfen vielleicht kann jemand altes
brot brötchen gebrauchen abholung in
remseck und ich denke mir eigentlich
haye auf den ersten blick was ist das
ein komisches angebot auf dem zweiten
blick und mal beim drüber nachdenken
denke ich mal allerdings ich bin ich
aufgewachsen in bielefeld und import von
wieder fällt so ein bisschen so bauern
mäßig blabla und da gab's eine re farm
keine ahnung wie man das genau geht so
ein gehege mit so reden und mit hirschen
und so und da haben wir immer wenn wir
brot übrig hatten haben wir das den
tieren da mitgebracht so dass sie das
halt essen konnten also war ich halt
irgendwie sechs jahre alt oder so und
ich glaube einfach dass das wirklich
auch seine mutter war und die sich jetzt
einfach vielleicht denkt hey die rehe
keine ahnung sind alle gestorben oder
und jetzt verkaufe ich mein brot bei
ebay oder verschenkt halt also ich finde
es eigentlich ein lustiges cooles
angebot
machen wir jedoch direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten liebe fällt jedoch nicht mit
einem angebot sondern mit einem chat und
zwar schreibt ja eine person dank herr
ist paypal zahlung möglich darauf
antwortet der typ ja auch möglich aber
bitte als freunde senden damit keine
gebühren entstehen
dann schickt er noch seine paypal
emailadresse und fragt dann einen tag
später hallo besteht noch interesse oder
darf ich es weiter verkaufen mit
freundlichen grüßen und die person
antwortet dann wir sind keine freunde
erzählen wollen wir nun jedoch wieder zu
einem richtigen ebay angebot und zwar
ist das hier das ist eine professionelle
blitzer sitzer für 899 euro verhandelt
hallo ich bin ein professioneller
blitzer sind zwar komme gerne bei ihren
blitzer vorbei und sitze den ganzen tag
davor zu dieser zeit können sie den
unproblematisch die geschwindigkeiten
erhöhen der blitzer löst dann zwar aus
jedoch wird nur ein foto von mir gemacht
der preis ist 890 euro pro tag hört sich
sehr viel an aber überlegen sie doch mal
wenn 900 fahrer die sowieso jede stunde
beziehungsweise tag vorbei von mir nur 1
euro überweisen ist es wenig geld für
straßen die wenig befahren werden mache
ich auch vergünstigungen also das nenne
ich mal ein soziales angebot der nächste
ebay feldes wieder einen chat verlauf
und zwar verkaufte jemand seinen ikea
schuhschrank oder bekommt die nachricht
wir nehmen den schrank auf jeden fall
und überlegen uns wie wir den
schnellstmöglich abholen können okay
er antwortet direkt okay eine halbe
stunde später kommt dann allerdings die
nachricht wir haben das noch mal
besprochen und ein auto zu kaufen ist
uns insgesamt zu teuer wir nehmen ihn
leider doch nicht sorry
das hier ist das nächste ebay angebot
das ich gefunden habe und das hört sich
auch erst mal so wenn man sich nur den
titel durch ließ komplett vernünftig und
legitim an einer verkauft seine küche
und der preise ist verhandelbar das foto
was allerdings damit bei es ist das hier
ja familie ritter wird die küche
bestimmt nehmen das jetzt eine anzeige
machen werde auch direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten event frage ich mich beim
nächsten liebefeld wirklich wieder
stellen dass leute wirklich rein um
dadurch sich zu erhoffen dass sie
dadurch geld machen
es geht nämlich um das hier der populär
wurde von meiner nase hergestellt und in
der beschreibung steht sehr
geschmackvoll
also ja ein euro da will ich direkt
zugreifen die nächste ebay fail ist eine
kombination aus einem übels lustigen
titel aus dem lustigen fotos aus dem
lustigen text also ich zeige euch
erstmal das foto es geht um diese couch
der titel dieses angebots ist übel
hässliche couch zu verschenken
da gebe ich dir recht tatsächlich das
lustig für das ganzen angeboten ist
allerdings meiner ansicht nach der
beschreibungstext und zwar steht dort
hässlichste couch des jahrhunderts zu
verschenken bei ihrem anblick wird mir
seit jahren schlecht das ding ist so
hässlich dass gibt's gar nicht die maße
dieses wirklich furchtbar geschmacklosen
möbelstücks in 150 langen und 60 breit
bitte befreit mich von diesem augen
krebs verursachenden stück des
schlechten geschmacks dem abholer
schenke nicht sogar noch 20 euro bitte
um baldige erlösung oder denke ich mir
einfach ein geiler text bitte ich um auf
folglich würde das ding abnehmen das
hier ist der nächste querfeld ihr seht
schon das bild und auf dem titel schnee
zu verschenken und wenn wir mal die
beschreibung anschauen sehen wir schon
einfach vorbeikommen mit was auch immer
lkw kühltasche eierbecher et cetera mir
egal ja also ich transportiere schnee
immer im eierbecher allerdings steht in
der beschreibung des angebots weiterhin
geschrieben damit erzeugen mächtig auf
die nüsse geht und nachschub
ununterbrochen fällt kann jeder schnee
holen so viel wie er will und weg
bekommen soll ja welche geben die keinen
haben somit habt ihr auch die chance
euch den traum vom schnee zu erfüllen
ja das ist ja sehr sozial ich würde dann
nächste woche donnerstag mit einem
eierbecher vorbeikommen bei diesem
liebefeld schreibt eine person dem
verkäufer eines produktes 300 euro
fragezeichen schickt dazu noch seine
telefonnummer also fragt aber das
produkt auch günstiger bekommt und
daraufhin antwortet der verkäufer
einfach 1150 er will also ja 850 euro
mehr
daraufhin geht der andere nicht hoch mit
seinem angebot sondern noch mal runter
auf 250 euro
daraufhin geht der verkäufer auf 5000
euro hoch ihr verhandelt wie zwei kamele
in der wüste als nächstes verkauft
jemand auf ebay seine waschmaschine und
wir sehen schon das foto hier das ist
eine komplett normale waschmaschine
vielleicht ein bisschen der ältere
waschmaschine aber er schreibt auf jeden
fall in den titel des produkts machen
machen 125 euro lüdenscheid katze dinge
abholen
in der beschreibung steht sehr gut wach
machen also wenn ich das nächste mal
beim autofahren bisschen müde bin will
ich dann einfach kurz bei einer
waschmaschine vorbeischauen wenn ihr
einen so gut wach machen kann kann ne
das nächste angebot hätte so krass von
mir sein können uns war verkaufte jemand
seinen staubsauger der noch
funktionsfähig ist allerdings seht ihr
schon da ist eine spinne mit buy und in
den beschreibungstext steht kein witz
verkauf um einen funktionsfähigen
staubsauger leider habe ich damit eine
spinne aufgesaugt und deshalb das rohr
zugeklebt ich habe angst vor jeder noch
so kleinen spinnen und kann ihn daher
auch auf keinen fall vorverkauf lehrern
sorry
angebot könnte wirklich 2000 von mir
sein denn easybell fail es kein
richtiger ebay fail sondern ist es mehr
so ein angebot was ich entdeckt habe wo
ich mir wirklich einfach dachte wo warum
und wie ich zeig euch einfach mal uns
war verkaufte jemand diese karte
beziehungsweise verschenkt diese karte
und das ist die uno karte dass die
richtung geändert wird und bei dem bild
ihr seht schon der held das und ein
wasserstrahl und da geht das wasser
einfach in die andere richtung klar das
wird wahrscheinlich mit irgendwem etwas
durchsichtiges plastikschlauch gemacht
oder so der unternehmer befestigen im
wasser haben aber diese idee dass man
sich denkt hey das ist zwar lustig aber
anstatt dass ich das jetzt irgendwie
weiß ich nicht auf instagram posten oft
an ihm seite oder auf mein geld whatever
kostet das einfach auf ebay als joke van
dyck mégane als das nächste angebot ist
allerdings nicht so ein innovativer job
sag ich mal den jedoch wieder
hochgeladen hat sondern jemand bietet an
einen hund zu erschrecken
ich erschrecke ihren hund steht auch in
der beschreibung und der will 20 euro
pro erstreckung das heißt ja nicht dass
erschrecken 20 euro pro erschrecken ist
wirklich korrektes deutsch war wir auch
weiter mit dem nächsten ebay fail und
zwar sieht das andere das war komplett
normal aus niemand verkauft seine apple
watch 150 euro art apple-gerät und
zubehör zustand neu steht dort
allerdings steht hinter der apple watch
organisch da denkt man sich etwas meint
er mit organisch bis man sich dann das
foto an schaut ja
es ist einfach ein apfel machen wir
nicht weiter mit dem nächsten ebay feld
und zwar verkauft hier nicht jemand
etwas oder verschenkt auch nicht sondern
er sucht etwas und zwar hässlichen
felgen für sich und sehr sehr hässliches
auto
ich würde am liebsten wieder klatschen
aber ich habe schon noch geklappt die
nächstenliebe fällen finde ich auch auf
der einen seite zwar hart lustig aber
auf der andern seite irgendwie traurig
wenn das ernst meint er tauscht nämlich
seinen hamster gegen eine ps4 pro woche
der beschreibung so richtig stumpf ich
tausche diesen haben es dagegen eine ps4
pro bei interesse einfach an schreiben
also ja ich würde den hamster gern
retten ich würde meine ps4 sogar dafür
wollen wir allerdings nun doch schon zum
letzten liebefeld für heute und zwar
geht es um eine uhr und zwar eine rolex
submariner und ein potenzieller käufer
fragt welches jahr schickt auch seine
telefonnummer dazu und der verkäufer
antwortet einfach ganzer satz so ich
wüsste auch nicht was damit welches jahr
genau meint meinte jetzt das baujahr der
uhr weil er die uhr gekauft hat keine
ahnung was da auf ihn hat sich der
typischen wie ein bisschen getriggert
gefühlt und dann einfach geschrieben aus
welchen gerade eine hässliche uhr will
ich nicht mehr an deiner stelle erst mal
nach freundlichkeit auf die besucher an
der stelle wird das heute geht jetzt
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde ganz ganz ganz ganz viele von
euch haben unter meiner letzten videos
geschrieben 'hallo carlos war diese
liebefeld serie eigentlich unverändert
aber es war echt ziemlich lustig von
daher wäre cool wenn du da noch mal ein
paar von machen würdest deswegen hab ich
das hier heute gemacht wenn es euch
gefallen da würde ich mich auf jeden
fall sehr sehr toll war einen daumen
hoch von euch unter dem video für freund
schreibt ihn in die kommentare
welchen ebay fällt ihr am crazy ist
empfindet also wenn ihr wirklich noch
was auf ebay geschaut hätte und er hat
ein von diesem feld gefunden wo hättet
ihr euch gedacht hey was ist mit dem
falsch aber nicht zu dem video main
kanal ist es kostenlos und verpasst
keine videos mehr und wenn ich schon
aber dann will ich mich aus als hätte
der ball freuen wenn ihr auf die glocke
klicken würdet dann dadurch bekommt der
benachrichtigung sobald ich neues video
hochladen und ich werde langsam wieder
gesund danke für die nachfrage und den
letzten videos also trotz muss jetzt
nicht mehr wussten auch nicht mehr aber
trotzdem für sie mich jetzt wieder in
mein bett
[Musik]